bonsoir dévoile l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs ce soir
deux invités tout d'abord le champion du
portugal junior une 180 josé de sousa
wii blanche bonsoir pitot et voudrait
tant porter donc en profiter puisque là
les portugais peuvent nous écouter bono
ita et notre guest stars habituelles
nicolas magic giffords en sort comme ça
alors nicolas dans ton actualité
c'est ainsi c'est il ya un nouveau livre
qui vient de sortir aux éditions
bonderman alors on va en parler un petit
peu c'est alors cette fois c'est un
livre non plus sur l'histoire des
champions et et les grands tournois mais
pour les débutants pour apprendre à
jouer aux échecs sans exercice pour
progresser aux échecs
chez borneman par nicolas giffard et
jacques et le biais là je je le montre à
l'écran
nicolas tu peux nous parler un peu de ce
de ce livre et du principe de ce livre
qui est un peu particulier c'est un
livre qui est conçu pour l'interactivité
maximum entre le lecteur et le contenu
le lecteur a donc sans exercice à
résoudre et voyez donc comme si chaque
page montre chaque page comporte deux
exercices chaque exercice à sa solution
sur la page suivante donc invisibles
parce que tous les exercices sur les
pages de droite
ces solutions sont sur les pages de
gauche qu'on ne peut voir donc quand en
retournant la page on n'a donc pas aller
au bout du livre pour avoir la solution
est dans chaque solution on explique à
un principe du jeu ça une petite morale
disons à chaque
exercice et voilà c'est un en même temps
livres pour chercher et pour apprendre
voilà donc ces listes retrait progressif
puisque des problèmes vont du plus
simple au oui c'est à dire disons que
l'on l'a fait pour mettre les questions
concernant les ouvertures au début du
livre celle concernant le milieu de
partie tactique et stratégie sont un peu
séparés au milieu du livre donc et puis
à la fin du livre
les exercices concernant les finales
alors avec un précis qu'on retrouve
aussi nicolas dans l'est dans les
magazines dans les lits dans les
journaux qui parlent d'échec qui
essaient d'évaluer un petit peu le
niveau
oui du lecteur est donc là ce livre
s'adresse aux joueurs classés entre
débutants complets et initie son coin
comme tu les serveurs on a conçu des
points à distribuer en fonction de la
résolution des exercices de telle
manière que celui qui trouve tout un
1600 lots alors bien sûr c'est un peu
aléatoire c'est un peu approximatif
comme jugement de deux niveaux
mais bon voilà l'idée c'était ça c'est
si on résout 100% des problèmes on à
1600 points elo le prochain livre est
prévue pour faire une barre à 1800 et le
troisième à 2000 abonnés ce qui devient
un niveau international c'est la limite
le classement est à l'affairé on
essaiera faire des exemples plus dû
retirer un peu aussi bien pour jacques
el bia que pour moi même de nous notre
expérience de joueur
donc voilà nicolas giffard ngambia sorte
un nouveau livre aux éditions borneman
sans exercice pour progresser je leur
montre encore la caméra donc disponible
dans toutes les bonnes librairies
voilà un petit commentaire je pense que
pour progresser il ya vraiment que la
recherche justement des exercices comme
ça pour progresser ces scans mieux
pensés par la recherche qu'on progresse
voilà ce que je disais aussi nicolas
l'émission c'est que ce livre sur le
concept ressemble un petit peu oui en
effet bobby fischer en fait il a fait de
livres dans les 60 meilleures parties et
avant j'avais fait un livre pour
l'initiation au jeu et ça le principe
dix on était un peu pareil
un peu moins avec mais a fourni avec la
proximité des solutions moi j'avais le
souvenir pour faire ce livre ce qui m'a
donné l'idée c'est le livre de yang sari
or tu sais pas si j'osais je vénère et
le meilleur s'appelle le meilleur coût
en allemand et en anglais on peut le
trouver malheureusement pas en français
et qui avait donc ce principe d'un
exercice avec sa solution derrière
cachés et qu'on peut voir en retournant
simplement la page et c'est un livre
très très puissant pédagogiquement parce
que les deux grands maîtres aussi bien
en deçà york donner des exemples de
leurs propres pratiques effet été très
péremptoire dans la solution disait il
faut jouer si ils faisaient ça pouvait
évidemment être contestable mais le
grand maître affirmé ça et comme il
avait joué au même la partie il avait
analysé longtemps je crois qu'on peut
leur faire confiance d'ailleurs j'avais
décelé très très peu d'erreurs même
maintenant avec l'informatique dans leur
analyse on voit peu d'erreurs c'est un
des meilleurs entraîneurs du monde qui
est vrai de ce qu'ils appliquent cette
méthode puisque chaque fois il donne des
exercices comme ça
très souvent donc voilà donc ça restait
très bien sans exercice pour progresser
aux échecs
voilà de nicolas j fort encore un
best-seller à venir ça n'arrête pas
nicolas au prix modique de 79 francs
ibérique toujours alors l'actualité
cette semaine on va on va y venir c'est
avant tout
le championnat du monde junior qui se
déroule donc à erevan en arménie avant
de commencer à parler de ce championnat
du monde on va revenir sur les sujets
qu'on avait abordé la semaine dernière
donc les émissions de diagonale sont
toujours disponibles en différé vous
pourrez y revenir vous donc sur
l'émission de la semaine dernière on va
continuer avec donc cette semaine notre
interview de donc de l'inauguration au
jardin du luxembourg à paris un espace
échiquier où beaucoup de personnalités
étaient présentes dont la champion de
france en 1999 christine clients bonjour
toujours dans le jardin du sénat cette
fois et christine finir championne de
france 99 bonjour festive bonjour à et
loire alors tu habites à montpellier tu
es championne de france et tu viens à
paris alors pourquoi pourquoi venir au
sénat est ce que tu t'es content d'être
là et pourquoi tu es tu venu d'abord
parce que j'ai été invité à manger avec
le président donc monsieur poncelet et
cette idée une très belle occasion
pour moi de venir à paris l'inaugurer ce
jardin du luxembourg
c'est échiquier pam en super donc tu une
ambassadrice des jeux d'échecs en fait
maintenant un peu ça ouais c'est une
partie de la vieille dame est ton
actualité après sur quatre ans tu veux
jouer des tournois tu vas partir un peu
partout bien j'aime m'occuper de mes
débuts mais deux enfants d'abord un
petit peu et puis ensuite j'irai jouer
le championnat d'europe en géorgie au
mois de novembre
d'accord donc très bonne actualité merci
christine voilà donc la championne de
france christine pierre champion de
france 1999
donc on revient à ce ce championnat du
monde junior donc en arménie beaucoup de
monde
on a discuté un petit peu avant nicolas
josé de très très fort joueur
ah oui championnats du monde juniors
très relevé comme tous les ans en fait
de très fort joueur on note l'absence ce
nom de peut-être ponomariov bacrot qui
sont plus jeunes mais qui aurait fait
plus partie b dont on aurait aimé les
voir se confronter à un bond à ses
joueurs qui sont quand même très fort et
le champion c'est galkin - russe le seul
russe du tournoi si je puis dire nous
et puis gagne le temps il est très forte
donc les re s'arrête pas de nicolas de
sortir des apparats mans il était en
tête tout le tournoi
il était détaché auprès trois quatre ans
mais il a toujours gardé la tête et la
dernière ronde il a battu casting josh
voilà il termine donc il le relève ma
5ème 6ème place kassim janov que bioware
a battu reste vegas oui oui oui les
quelque 2600 au point donc bon depuis
qu'ils s'en prennent aux donc c'est ça
montre le niveau quand même du temps
j'ignore si moins de 20 ans en pleine
moins de 20 ans mais au fait des joueurs
mémé et c'était encore plus jeunes
peuvent quand même participer au tournoi
bien sûr et donc de ses 20 ans alors
parmi tous ces joueurs de l'ess parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de joueurs ne laisse
dans les premières places
on va en trouver quand même on avait un
français qui était là-bas on qui a très
bien figuré
oui c'est 6 rue marcellin je dirais
c'est plus la nouvelle génération c'est
la renouvelle c'est encore tout gène
quoi c'est la série de marcelin il a 20
ans je crois juste ça peut pas il doit
être limite de la catégorie et il a joué
apparemment tout le tournoi aux
alentours de la table numéro 10 donc il
n'a jamais lâché groupe pas tout à fait
de tête mais juste un peu derrière il a
fait un très beau tourner à mon avis
doit faire une performance à plus de
2500 c'est d'ailleurs presque sûr je
crois qu'il perd qu'une partie sur deux
sur honda tous les 12 ou 13 secondes
c'était très long
c'est très simple il a perdu tous ses
voûtes shkin justement qui finissent 5/8
dans les toutes dernières rondes donc ça
veut dire que bon s'il avait battu il
luttait pour les toutes premières places
malheureusement ses muscles et un très
fort joueur aussi donc
alors donc très très joli tournoi de
cyril martinez c'est pourquoi cette
semaine nous allons étudier ni c'est
parti et la semaine prochaine
invité exceptionnel diagonale juste
devant cyril marcellin donc 6 rue
marcellin zannou prochaine viendra
analyser son propre championnat du monde
junior sur diagonale donc en attendant
on va étudier enfin on va regarder tu
dis est un grand mot parce que on n'aura
pas le temps de tout voir évidemment
mais on va regarder une jolie partie de
cyril barcelone lors de ce championnat
du monde donc je vous rappelle que pour
suivre la partie avec nous vous la voyez
évidemment sur la vidéo vous avez être
deux autres possibilités vous allez sur
la planète jarrah en cliquant sur le
bouton de jouer à votre droite qui vous
donne une page vous pouvez
suivre la partie et autres possibilités
vous pouvez aussi charger le fichier de
la partie le fichier pgn comme c'est
indiqué sur le bouton et elle est
visible grâce à des programmes
téléchargeables dans la partie différée
de diagonale les explications sont
données à ce niveau là donc on va
démarrer la vision de cette de cette
partie donc peu cyril martiaux neil qui
a donc les blancs on va remettre la
partie au début puisqu'elle était déjà
un peu avancé donc c'est le marseillais
josé que tu que tu connais un peu parce
qu'il est de paris et je connais un peu
même s'ils n'ont pas ce que je faisais
était très jeune il voulait d'être
professionnel et il voulait travailler
les échecs et toujours beaucoup
travaillé les échecs et il aime ça et je
me souviens qu'il était donc 2200 et
commencer juste avec la scène
internationale et il voulait déjà des
professionnels et très fort joueur
participe au championnat du monde était
très ambitieux donc ça fait plaisir de
voir finalement ce niveau alors on va
voir les premiers coups de 7,2 cette
partie donc 6 rue marcellin qui démarre
avec les pièces donc blanche avec le
coup encore une fois pour les plus
classiques au centre on en a déjà parlé
aux échecs on essaie au début souvent de
dominer le centre de le
contrôler les quatre centrales je veux
dire aussi dire que oui nicolas connaît
très bien aussi syrie puisqu'il faut
dans le même club
on a joué qu'eux mêmes d'accord on a
joué agressif ou deux ans mais il a
quitté drancy il ya deux ans pour le
mans le mans s'arrête ne fait plus de
l'équipe en nationale 1 alors donc cyril
l'heure cela va jouer maintenant à meaux
l'équipe de mots beauval d'accord donc
ça s'est produit que la nationale dans
l'histoire d'un club français donc
l'adversaire répond avec un coup on en
symétrique qui va engager la partie sur
des ouvertures qu'on appelle mon dr
nicolas oui c'est un coût qui ne
s'occupent pas directement le centre qui
contrôle la case aux 5
donc cette case ici comment et avec qui
se répandent un peu freiné l'expansion
des blancs mais sans plus
on va passer les premiers coups donc le
coup deux t4 ensuite les noirs répondre
par le cavalier sur la case et 6 une
cours de développement logique qui
attaquent le pion qui attaquent le pion
développement des blancs en même temps
que de protection du plomb des pions
centrale toujours un développement
finalement qui contrôle les cases les
caisses centrales le cas des cadets 5,5
donc encore en courant devant nicolas le
premier coup d si c'était un courant
pendant encore un petit petit coup de
pions qui n'a pas l'air très agressif
oui c'est une femme qui est apparu qu'à
devenir un mode une dizaine d'années et
puis qui est retombé un peu dans les
oubliettes parce que elle a subi
quelques défaites assez cinglante
s'appelle la défense tchèque
si les noirs continuent ensuite en
sortant la dame qui est assez libéré sur
la case à 5
c'est une idée assez bizarroïde mais qui
a été à la mode pendant
une dizaine d'années je sais pas si j'ai
jusqu'au les pass est parti donc je ne
sais pas si ça a été serré continuation
alors on va voir donc sur une version
choisie un début aussi relativement de
prudent c'est pas un coût non plus très
agressif
non c'est pas le plus c'est le coup j'ai
dû en voilà mais c'est un coût qui a la
réputation d'être anglais les noirs
disons de l'oeil à tout fait de les
étouffer petit à petit le coup g2 g3 qui
préfigure le développement du fond blanc
et josé sur la case g2 ce qu'on appelle
un fou un film qui est ou qui
contrôlerait cette grande diagonale
personnellement j'aime beaucoup ce coup
parce que c'est vrai que la continuation
théorique autre que j'ai 3 cf 4 et l'a
rappelé coup bien sûr on joue des
médecins comme l'apprécient nicolas mais
ce que j'aime bien vous faites en
mettant le fou en g2c qui donne un
contrôle supplémentaire au point 4 qui
on va le voir peut s'avérer un peu
faible sur un développement notre
développement du fou et d'autre part on
ne pourrait croire que le fou sur cette
diagonale sur la diagonale h18 n'a pas
vraiment d'avenir puisque il ya le pion
c6 est en baisse 7 qui finalement le
l'empêchent de voir dans un horizon
voilà ce matin ses pions noirs sont
quasi blanche ici qui vont qui luttent
contre le fou ce que j'essaierai
démontrer que c'est pas si vrai par la
suite wuala alors on va voir
donc les noirs choisi sa de sortir
maintenant leur cavale l avantage de ce
coup nicolas c'est que ça contrôler une
nouvelle fois la case de 5 et vous
permettre aux noirs de jouer le coup
sept ans le 5 pour contre attaquer au
centre au total alors oui oui le noir
vont effectivement pousser leurs pions
du roi de 2 15 ans le 5
c'est la façon presque unique d'avoir un
contrôle du centre acceptable après
écoulant je veux juste préciser que le
problème des noirs le majeur problème
majeur des noirs c'est qu'ils n'ont
qu'une caste ont développé deux pièces
le fou ces 8es le cavaly des 8 parce que
donc si on met le cavalier en 17 aux
forges de cinq blocs l'horizon du fou
sémite
on se fout ne peut pas partir alors mais
si on sort vont donc ou sortir le fou
alors justement sur le sort on fume
kétou donc on va jouer b6 et bâle a
juste le fou qui temps j'ai deux va
commencer à prendre de l'ampleur
voilà donc ré
faudrait il faut éviter pour une noire
d'affaiblir ce côté là s'arrête sous le
sol
mais malheureusement il n'y a pas
vraiment d'autre solution pour
développer le fou c'est pour ça qu'au
lieu de cavaye 17 des fois où je fous g4
mais c'est ils ont un coût un autre coup
que cavalli 17 beaucoup d'opportunités
en tout cas voilà donc on va voir
donc les blancs mais tel un chemin coup
alors équipe à partir de ce coup mérite
commentaires nicolas on s'attend à ce
que les blancs en face ce titre le fou
mettre leurs fous sur la casse j'ai deux
sortes lecavalier est un jouet un coup
qui a l'air de ne pas s'occuper du
centre ne pas s'occuper de roquet non
plus qu'elle peut être l'idée de se
faire une idée c'est d'empêcher les
noirs de pousser leurs pions bessette en
d5 jean-paul idée et puis ça peut
éventuellement menacer de pousser encore
une fois ce pion ski et prend beaucoup d
espace donc je pense que les noirs vont
répliquer par a7 a51 monde je me trompe
pas ce que mme énormément les bars et
blanc pousser plus loin que à 4 ce pion
parce que justement un assassin qui
l'empêcherait peut-être des six pour
pour développer le fou ancien ghetto
mais il faut préciser aussi que l'idée
bessette b5 et très forte parce qu'elle
menace b4 qui qui enlève le caire 24
attaques lecavalier et qui a l'air de la
montre prudent la ferme le contrôle de
cette destruction 4 qui qui peut
s'avérer faible comme tu le disais tout
à l'heure mais cette baie 5 est un coup
utile disons tour mais il ya beaucoup de
joueurs a créé blanc qui laisse faire ce
métier le plus intéressant alors on va
voir
donc les noirs ne choisisse choisi de ne
pas répondre mais de contre attaquer au
centre en tout cas de se développer
plutôt que de contre attaquer se
développer au centre ce qui secoue
permet tout simplement non seulement
d'avoir une action central de cette
arrestation mais aussi de pouvoir sortir
le fouet fuite ici sur la case de 7 pour
permettre le petit rock au noir alors à
la place des blancs
je pousserai ce pion une nouvelle fois
on a cinq mais peut-être qu'il a choisi
de jouer cavalier e 2 qui est aussi un
coût alors il effectivement il a choisi
le coup car yodel pourquoi donc plutôt
coriace 3 nicolas sûrement parce que
pour ne pas gérer le fou qui veut
s'installer aux fientes et voilà le fou
qui va s'installer un g2 a besoin
d'avoir de l'espace pour en voir de
l'action donc le carrière de une
peut-être moins gênant f3 mais bush ou
parce que comme l'idée de fous j'ai deux
c'est de justement de contrôler quatre
places et le cavalier devant le fou
contredirait un peu complètement le
développement des bains don camillo 2
c'est le coût normal donc au 6e coulée
noire répandre logiquement par la sortie
de leur fou de 15 mois qui va leur
permettre ensuite de mettre le roi à
l'abri en faisant le petit rock et
l'autre idée ici c'est bon on va voir
comment ce des renforts mais toujours
d'une ouverture sur les joueurs savent à
peu près ce qu'il veut le faire à ce
moment de la partie
en général les deux camps dans ce genre
de position centrale font le petit rock
s'est vite alors 7 pour les blancs fou
j'ai deux logiques
c'est exactement le coût pour pour
lequel j'ai trois étés a été joué
maintenant les noirs retarde un peu le
petit rock en mettant la dame sur la
casse et 7
alors pourquoi mettre la dame sur cette
case là on peut se poser la question je
pense que ils ont vu que les blancs ont
un plan possible qui est de pousser f2f
4 et à mon avis ce coup d'oeil mais
destinée déjà à l'avance à contrôler la
case centrale russe a donc encore une
surprotection 7,4 cette case de 5 est
protégé par le pion des six par le
cavalier en 17 et maintenant la dame se
postent ici ou là une nation au moins
défensive le joueur électrique ou
profils actifs pour éviter pour éviter
des problèmes plus tard
donc petit rôle pour les blancs là les
noirs choisissent de ne pas faire le
petit rock mais de lancer une attaque
non la ccvo chellata sa chance qui nous
est complètement imprévue et
dans le joueur noir avait dans l'idée
non pas le jeu normal à partir de cette
ouverture mais une idée d' attaque sans
roque et donc le roi noir a plutôt
l'idée sans doute d'aller faire le grand
roque à gauche vous de rester au centre
est tout de suite ils dansent une
attaque contre le roi blanc alors le
problème effectivement quand tu le dis
c'est les noirs ne manquent pas donc si
leur voir rester au centre on peut cette
tour au fond ça tout aura 8 ne va pas
jouer mais on sait vraiment ce que n'a
pas joué c'est donc il faut faire
attention à ce problème là quand on
engage ce type d'action forcément je
pense que c'est un mauvais coup de
jamais parce que j'ai pas l'utilité du
coup h5 disons à parapher bien la fois
ils sont des noirs ils peuvent pas grand
roque et parce que les blancs vont tout
de suite lancé une attaque à l d'ampara
5 par exemple
en plus ils doivent développer le fou
ces huit avants de grand hockey donc je
pense que c'est un coup affaiblissant un
coup disons deux jeunes en fait oui
un comble si les coups d'oeil on traite
même ce genre de coude d'attac de café
c'est à dire que qui ne marche que dans
la rigolade et en partie sérieuse ne
marche pas alors on va en voir ensuite
donc la levée du corps est planté on
peut dire que l'ouverture est terminée
les noirs ont dévoilé leur plan qui
décide d'attaquer les blancs sont aussi
serait parce qu'ils ont repris un
développement relativement sain donc ils
vont essayer de coordonner coordonner
leurs forces ce qui va être le problème
des noirs probablement pas le problème
des noirs ça va être la l'emplacement du
roi qui est très délicat
la praticité - qui dort l'instant qui
pointent s'entraîne au centre est ce que
finalement c'était blanc qui vont
attaquer très vite le roi noir alors que
parce qu'ils sont mieux développer puis
une épée sont mieux coordonnés dit alors
on va voir avant de continuer l'analyse
cette partie on va continuer sur
le jardin du luxembourg avec une encore
une interview donc s'est déroulé lors de
cette inauguration avec justement une
colle à giffard
alors donc toujours au sénat après
christine flir on voit que dès qu'on
parle un petit peu femme d'un lieu de
déchets qui a les hommes qui arrivent
alors on en à nicolas giffard
bonjour nicolas bonjour stéphane belle
ambiance ici j'ai rencontré christine
flir je voudrais vous présenter que
c'est le faire s'il ya encore des gens
ne la connaissent pas une anecdote il ya
une bonne quinzaine d'années on peut
dire j'étais à créteil pour faire une
simultanée il ya une petite fille une
gamine avec des tresses et puis j'ai
joué très vite quand je passais devant
elle et je me suis fait complètement
ratatiner voilà 7 et christine fuyant et
oui on est on est on n'avait pas
championne de france par hasard et on
est aussi avec elle a encore le
vice-champion de france avant de
rencontrer etienne bacrot le champion de
france dimanche
albert et là on a le vice-champion de
france david marciano ouvrons soir david
de toulouse d'ailleurs de toulouse mais
là par hasard puisque ma petite copine
habite tout près donc je suis passé sans
même savoir qu'il se passait quelque
chose ici et puis c'est elle qui a
découvert un parfum ya trois jours on
lui a dit qu'il se passe est un
événement important alors j'en ai
profité
heureux d'être là c'est sympa quand je
reviens je connaissais pas alors c'est
un peu le hasard c'est le côté mystique
du jeu d'échecs comme ça je sais pas si
c'est mystique que ma copine étudier à
paris mais en tout cas c'est vrai que
c'est une coïncidence heureuse que je
sois là en ce moment et puis je trouve
c'est agréable de voir tous ces gens
donc voilà ici au sénat décidément la
crème des échecs est présente à vous
paris bonjour voila a nous paris donc
voilà donc petite interview on a vu
le vice-champion de france à nicolas
willot david martinon la révélation de
besançon là on pensait pas le voir
éliminés notamment l'outil et c'est lui
qui a provoqué l'élimination de l'authie
numéro un français et ouais oui il avait
déjà quand même titiller aux
championnats de france par équipes en
nationale 1 où il était passé tout près
de la victoire et il est fini par perdre
donc là
je n'ai pas été surpris finalement parce
qu'ils travaillent énormément il
il est très sérieux et je pense qu'on
sous estime les coûts voilà jusqu'à
présent on l'a vu faire mule contre des
joueurs très très fort bon on a comme ça
que la fée marciano comme le joueur qui
fait nul et même contre doit battre
battre l'un lautier on ne pensait pas
capable donc voilà l'a démontré dans ces
championnats de france
donc voilà on revient donc à ses deux
parties où le décor est planté et on va
voir le bon collard action de 6 rue
marcellin il a joué un coup intéressant
c'est le court h2 h3 nicolas qui empêche
la rupture nord est née l'idée c'est de
fermer le jeu si les noirs pousse à
nouveau leurs pions qui viennent de ses
précédents avec les vélos bloc le jeu
par un voile et noir ont une idée de
pousser leurs pions pour échanger ce
pion ici est libéré l'action de la tour
en fait sur l'heure voire adverse et un
jour ce que moi je lâche 3 et blanc
protège la case g4 et donc sur le coup h
4 comme tu le viens de le dire le coût
de blocage g3 g4 empêcherait les noirs
d'avoir toute action moi j'aime bien ce
coup parce qu'il a deux buts
d'une part il défend parce que bon soit
4 ont bougé kate et finalement cet été
blanc qui m'ont attaqué mais en plus il
permet fouet 300 ils permettent faut 3
sans avoir peur de cavaler g4 qui
attaquent le fou ou 3 1 il faut donc pas
donc à n'ayant pas peur d'un échange la
satisfait
ce peut être favorable pour les pour les
pour les noirs puisque moi le foot 15 -
souvent très bon en ce jour d'ouverture
donc c'est un j'aime bien ce genre de
cookies même temps défendre et attaque
alors on va voir comment commence à se
dire maintenant
alors voilà un coup comme on me disait
tout à l'heure le cac est utilisé il
avait le peu de pièces pleines un peu
d'endroits de développement il rit que
la casse des scènes vraiment envie
efficace et on voit qu'après il a pas
beaucoup de classe non plus par hasard
que là il se retrouve à essayer d'aller
sur le cas des fuites qui est pour
l'instant par une caste très très active
on voit très bien en fait que la
stratégie des noirs est un peu
compromise parce qu'elle est obligée de
jouer du coup comme ça après bout de
neuf coups dans une cc pas très typique
disons c'est merveilleux mais bon le
coup qu'on trouvait mystérieux tout à
l'heure de la dame noire ans et 7
on le comprend mieux maintenant qu'on a
vu les intentions des noirs étaient de
de faire le grand roque et donc socke ou
de dame noire et un peu mieux expliquer
maintenant alors il dit aussi de jouer
le coup donc de mesurer la dame noire
ans est maintenant le cas rien et fuite
va permettre aux fous de cases blanches
sortir et peut-être d'après de fer
laurenque donc je sais pas si c'est
vraiment prémédité disons comme comme
approche ce qu'il a vraiment joué à h5
en essayant les d'avoir quoi était ce
qui a changé d'âme ses 7 h 5 avait des
fuites dans les dons de faire grand roc
ou alors est-ce que c'est finalement au
vu des difficultés qu'ils rencontrent
qui trouve ses coûts à 91 délibéré il
est pas mis en difficulté et blanc n'ont
fait aucune ouais mais oui on va voir
l'entente mais on va voir en parlera
donc maintenant syrie continue son
développement pour marquer que tous les
coups de dés blancs ont l'air sain c'est
à dire que c'est ils répondent tous à
des objectifs volet-là cycle de
développement pièces de contrôle du
centre il s'occupe plus du centre que le
me le font des noirs je sais prévint
donc qu'elles sont mieux coordonnés dans
toutes les pièces maintenant blanches
sont sortis ils n'ont pas de point de
l'espace le roi a déjà rockets donc les
tours peuvent rentrer en jeu à tout
moment si le jeu s'ouvre par les noms
restent avec le problème du fou en série
qui n'est toujours pas développer la
tour en 1 8
non plus et ce cavalier suite qu'il faut
il faut qu'il trouve aussi
tu es sur la case aussi sous sur la
casse j'ai six emplois imaginer que les
morts pourrait attaquer en métamatériaux
langis 6 et puis c'est de faire une
attaque sur le court sur le côté droit
mais on voit mal où sont les faiblesses
du côté mélange parce qu'il faut s'y
attaquent une fée mais ce n'est qu'au
général voilà l'idée des noirs ces deux
ferries le roi blanc et pour ce faire je
vois qu'une manoeuvre actuellement ça
serait de doubler sur la diagonale ses 8
h 3 les forces pour attaquer ce pion
c'est à dire jouer d'abord fou s'est
vite en aussi sous 1 17 puis la dame sur
la même diagonale ensuite pour attaquer
deux fois le pion du rock à côté de
roland mais ça semble assez assez limité
les gommes possibilité d' attaque
effectivement il ya il semble pas qui
est assez d'ingrédients pour attaquer le
roi blanc avec succès parce que
normalement en fait c'est le gang
disons qu'ils aient comme nokia
regrouper le maximum de forces qui les
pièces lit mieux coordonnée qui est en
fait jaillir endroit l'attaqué ou hippie
ces endroits et puis est en position
d'attaquer là les noirs n'ont donc c'est
pour ça que c'est un peu curieux sur le
fond mais orthodoxe six mois à lorient
10e coulée noire choisissent de jouer
finalement pour le coup qu'on avait
envisagé tout au tout début pour sortir
ce fou finalement vraiment je trouve là
par contre par rapport au coût cavalli
fit carrière de libérer le fou je me
secoue 2 7 v6 sera pas en service à
palerme et voilà ça a pas l'air d'être
très cohérent puisque le foot maintenant
sortir des deux côtés bon mais il
n'aurait pu jouer dans ce cas là le
comble et 7 v6 tout de suite parce que
l'on a l'impression que le cam 17 était
mieux placé les tarifs 8 et les ultimes
essais en est là c'est vrai qu'il ya une
cohérence entre les alors le gros
problème que doivent affronter les noirs
là c'est que il voit très bien déferler
certainement le pion blanc 2f 2f 4 dans
les coûts prochain donc le pion bien
leur en f4 pour faire pression sur 130
on va faire exploser un peu la position
donc il doit prévoir quelque chose
contre ça et c'est pas facile alors
voyons maintenant 29
voilà c'est dit et serena se dessine aux
4 11e coup donc pouvait leur ferrer sur
votre logiciel sur la place jamal 11e
coup des blancs se décident de faire une
explosion du centre contre les nicolas
avec ce couac de en f4 les pions blancs
maintenance ont postés
centralement parlant sur la case 5
alors il ya effectivement l'idée par
l'idée de prendre en cinq peut-être
aussi l'idée de gagner de l'espace à
droite avec la poussée a une nouvelle
fois de soutien qui vient d'être poussé
à f/5 peut-être il a ces deux
possibilités avec le pion à f/5
notamment il empêcherait à la fois le
fou noir de ses 8 et puis le cavalier
fuite de jouer donc c'est très très fort
parce que même les noirs n'ont pas
intérêt à échanger leurs tons centrale
s'il échange leur pee 5
il enlève toute la fierté de leurs jeux
les plus là donc ils n'ont et n'auront
plus à montrer que un camp sur trois
rangées absolument mêmes tout de suite
on peut imaginer que celle ci noir
prennent en d4 on est quatre ensuite la
personne blanche aurait facilité dans le
cinq serait facilité sous quesnoy n'ont
pas encore développé leurs pièces mais
là il ya comme une menace concrète c'est
de prendre le 5 et pour jouer aux deux
de chute deux fois et de jouer d'après
d'harceler la dame qui sera obligée
venir entre 5 et d'avoir pris des
positions qui qui va délibérer en
surtout que ça libérerait la puissance
du fou j'ai 2 si on arrive à jouer un
jour et 5 parce que maintenant les noirs
ont affaibli les diagonales par mais si
oui c'est là que par des six semaines un
succès si ce n'est plus de 100 kg donc
compris magie si les blancs et a poussé
le pion aux 85
après les échanges de 104 est de chanter
ça la fou peut tout de suite se
réveiller et avoir une action dangereuse
donc là concrètement que montrer que si
les blancs menace de prendre ici donc
sur la reprise en hausse 1 qui
reprendrait une autre fournée 5
la dame viendra en 5 et après parents
même un coup comme fou au f4 ou fou des
quatre permettrait la vence justement de
ce pion aux cinq ans suite aux 4 5 avec
une pression se faisait 6 et des pièces
noires puis on a eu beaucoup de
problèmes
voilà ce qui forçait le roi toujours au
centre de retour au centre donc
susceptibles de subir des échecs des
tours
leur semaine qu'elle était champion de
france est dernière nous nous pas dit
que dit que le facteur le plus important
échec c'est le roi est donc là entre les
deux rois il ya manifestement sud est
mal en point
alors voyons donc les noirs choisissent
des scènes ramener une pièce au contrôle
central par le coup cavaliers en russie
ce donc là c'est très provocateur
vraiment c'est prendre garde et empêche
finalement l'idée empêche tout f4 enfin
deux variantes comme on a dit en tout
cas
mais ils on pare au plus pressé je pense
voyons donc si je choisis maintenant
voilà de faire une percée ici avec le
coût des quatre des cinq donc il fait
une double attaque sur le pion 6,6 et
lecavalier au cices et donc il va
probablement faire et même explosé un
peu tout ça mais tu aurais pu faire des
échanges en 5 des échanges en c6 donc
simplifier la position et peut-être
pouvoir attaquer le roi qui est toujours
le fait au centre ce coup là dans la
structure avec dans ces structures là
avec b 6 et 6 dé 6,5 contre eux cadre
des quatre le coût des quatre des cinq
est un coup à dix ont un coût typique
puisque ils attaquent tout de suite le
pion c6 qui a perdu sa base qui était
l'option b set puisqu'il a chopé sicile
c'est donc affaibli et c'est une réponse
standard d4 d5 danser mais peut-être que
nicolas et puis quand on est en règle
générale quand le roi de l'adversaire
est au centre on a intérêt à ouvrir le
jeu wii donc un coup comme ça
si lecavalier en ait six films même si
le cavalier tepa en et 6 le coût des
quatre dessins qui est un coût standard
dans ce genre de plus dans ce genre de
partie des 10 aux structures nos pions
voilà exactement sur votre connexion
merci non c'est souvent comme on dit
quand c'est typique dans ce genre de
position pensons à un tour en voiture
c'est la structure de pions exactement
dans cette structure option ce coup des
quêtes des cinq états côtiers
alors voyons la réaction des noirs c'est
une prise en r4 avec l'idée pour les
marine et blanc prennent le cavalier
évidemment on reprendrait le fou en e3
lanclas cyril choisi tout simplement de
reprendre le pion alors il reprend du
cavalier avec peut être l'idée ne pas
reprendre du poids pour que la tour à
tour et maintenant une action d'un quart
et demi je suis assez surpris
personnellement je m'attendais plutôt à
la reprise avec le pion pour valoriser
un peu de ses pions en exonérant les
vers le centre oui c'est une possibilité
effectivement reprendre avec le pion les
blanches garder la possibilité de faire
une percée au centre par an 4 5
tu attires il a vu plus loin il a
peut-être quelque chose déjà ses lacs
apparemment les noirs en l'air de
pouvoir échanger des cavaliers va et
soulager beaucoup la pression c'est vrai
mais peut-être série est un joueur assez
solide très solide qui aime pas trop
disons le facteur risque et donc ils
préfèrent garder un petit avantage
plutôt que de risquer par pions prend f4
qui bon détérioré un petit peu un peu la
position des droits blanc mais quinze
jours plus agressif aurait pris un f4
comme nicolas farine en faillite
l'option il garde quand même des
possibilités d'attaqué ne sert à quoi ça
si les noirs ont échangé je pense qu'ils
ont échangé leurs voix grave parce que
là la position encore critique il faut
absolument voir ce qui se passe donc là
les noirs choisi de prendre le cavalier
il reprend avec le flou gym et reprend
avec le fou syrie en premier le fou et
gardent la possibilité après ruth de nos
jours de faire ça va verser 100 soirée
c'est vrai donc en fait il ne perd pas à
cette possibilité
et puis menace aussi éventuellement
pions trempions là qui est très fort
parce que la dame noire peut pas
vraiment s'exposer oui alors c'est à
l'idée c'est que si les blancs prennent
en c6 les noirs reprendrai un c6 tout
simplement les blanche pourrait jouer le
coup eux 4 5 ou bien qu'ils aient un
petit échec qui attaquent la dame avec
le fou avec donc des possibilités
d'attaqués ont fait très fort très
important les fautes mais l'avait noir
vont échanger les pieds ou non alors
donc on va voir au 14e coup donc énorme
et choisi voilà de se développer
d'autres en finir là enfin de sortir ce
fou mais de le mettre sur une position
défensive alors que j'étais une femme
tout de suite voilà une position
défensive en 17 où il protège une avant
leurs points faibles en c6 oui c'est un
coup plein de sang froid parce que
il estime que les blancs ne menace pas
encore de percée au centre mais je suis
en train de calculer ça m'a l'air quand
même très risqué mais en tout cas
j'aimerais que je dois avouer que les
changes de cabello 6 contre le cavalier
de favoriser un peu quand même
la défense la défense et nature fait
raison je pense que là bon ça que j'y
joue un peu avec sang froid mais
peut-être que bon il a évité le pire si
aux cinq ne fonctionne pas mais en règle
générale le défenseur a intérêt à
échanger les pièces surtout les pièces
d' attaques adverses
hélas il semble si noir et pu le faire
mais c'est encore assez dynamique là
peut-être que les blancs peuvent percer
alors on va voir ce que choisit de faire
signer mais voilà il sort il sort sa
dame sur la colonne ici une robe noire
pourrait être en danger
on peut noter que moi on va en voir du
problème parce qu'ils peuvent choisir de
roquet maintenant nicolas
mais du côté grand roque salaires
faibles et de l'autre côté c'est la vie
mais aussi des rares côté aussi puisque
le pur noir est sorti l'été d'autres y
penser
et peut être même une cible en fait ce
qu on peut être une cible oui la tacc
nouara a dit ah mais sans dire b elle a
commencé par h5 elle s'est arrêtée là
c'est un clown triste
non mais si je continue la cité dorfman
là on dirait que la position du roi et
durablement mauvaises émotions du rhin
noir c'est à dire qu' il peut pas rester
au centre droit s'est durablement
mauvais puisqu'il a quand même compromis
sa structure et cash 5 et elle d'un
pareil donc le roi noir est vraiment en
difficulté manière durable
c'est un avantage durable sursis alors
voyons ce qui se passe maintenant
menouar choisissent quand même de faire
le petit rock c'est l'homme voilà que ce
courage sont finalement elles et un coup
dans l'eau il est devenu ridicule
oui parce qu'il aurait mieux valu que ce
pion restent prêts auprès du roman donc
la syrie le continue son action avec un
petit coup curieux notamment 16e coup il
joue le roi sur la case achat
encore un coup ou prophylactiques en
fait ouais mais là c'est curieux et
parce que disons que les coûts profit
d'actifs que je pense doit être fait
dans une position où on peut pas
améliorer
en fait c'est à dire on attend
tranquillement on quand on améliore
tranquillement la position que je dire
donc on joue rouach un ouvrage de
d'ailleurs qui peut-être en souhaitant
pas être meilleure mais là les noirs
peuvent améliorer leur position
peut-être qu'il fallait et blanc et
blanc ouais non les noirs à améliorer la
prévention est donc peut-être qu'il
fallait agir rapidement pour étouffer
tout de suite les noirs plutôt que de
jouer un coup plutôt que de jouer un
coup
d'attendre en fait on aurait imaginé
pour les blancs une centralisation de la
tour de la gauche d un grand centre qui
propose de fait simplement de prendre
ces six qui à mon avis un donne des pose
des problèmes aux eaux noires parce que
surtout on prend ces six comprend ces
six parcs en france et 6 pour les hommes
alors maintenant on joue cavalier b5 par
exemple quand il y avait cinq attaquants
la dame
et lequel l'option des 6 et le pion des
six obligerait les noirs à donner leur
fond plat s'ils donnent leur faut
maintenant on reprend avec le pion à en
b 5
oui hélas il ya beaucoup de faiblesses
il ya de plus on a 7 qui est sous feu de
la toile là alors c'est comme ça tac tac
bon il ya le pion des six donc que ça
donnerait une position assez assez bonne
meilleure encore pour les blancs je
pense que ce que secours h1 qui est qui
et prophylactique mais qui sait pas le
moment en fait indiqué je pense pour
jouer profit d'activités a failli jouer
énergique à mon sens
alors on continue cette partie avec la
tour maintenant des noirs et hongrois
qui vient au centre donc dans le centre
a salué noir se décident de jouer pour
le centre et place la tour devant la
dame blanche est un coup très utile
c'est un coût qui améliore énormément la
position des noirs série fait pression
directement sur la peau y sont blanches
donc mon avis les noirs ont peut-être
évité le pire en ce moment c'est à dire
peut-être évité le coup de massue
voilà alors maintenant on s'érige où
sont fous sur la case g5
alors c'est là où on voit qu'il fait
pression en fait sur sa faiblesse noire
le petit pion aux cinq puisque c'est le
cavalier qui le protège il fait pression
sur le défenseur en fait et menaces tout
simplement gagner un pion de gagner un
pion important puisque c'est un pion qui
défendent un petit peu laurent devoir
donc enfin qui était censé le faire en
tout cas au départ oui les noirs peuvent
pas protéger ce pion on notera stéphane
que s'il joue le coup qui est une grosse
erreur g7 g6 g7 g6 pour protéger le pion
aux 5 et bien le cavalier noir serait en
prise par deux pièces blanches protéger
une seule fois il sera donc perdu oui
puisque le fou et la tour ici gagnera
une pièce tout simplement sur le cas des
psys donc on voit mal comment les noirs
pour elles peuvent protéger nos talents
ce pion alors les noirs choisissent de
jouer le coup une contre attaque avec le
coup d'avancé ville extrait vue par
nicolas de ça qui était visé mais moi je
trouve c'est un très bon coup parce que
ça attaque h3 et en même temps sa menace
pétait cavaliers prend des 5
donc mon as peut-être cavaliers prendre
les chemins goudeau coups précédents les
pouvait rimer là surtout le coup
précédent il attaquait la d'avancé cette
famille c'est à dire que le mali pouvait
reprendre cavaliers attaquant la dame
et maintenant la menace les blancs vu
prendre le virage 5 dans les menaces qui
va les prendre et 5 est forte sur quelle
étrange où pranger 5e puis bon mais un
peu disons d'animation donc lors de ses
8 c'est un bon coup de défense je pense
attaque et défend même temps que s'ils
ont choisi de prendre sur la casse ces
six avec les dixie d'ivoire prennent
soin du futsal a damé le pion jeux 3d
plus attaquées bien sûr tout simplement
une année noire choisissent quand même
mais d'attaqués d'essayer d'attaquer le
roi de berck c'est en prenant le pion h
3 1 mais je pense qu'il ya un essayant
de supprimer le défenseur du roi et
essayer de faire des menaces nouvelles
et les noix en fait et c'est de pêcher
un peu en eaux troubles mais c'est un
bon coup franc à je crois hélas cyril
donc choisit maintenant de prendre le
cavalier sur la case et fils qui a l'air
aussi d'autres bons coups en fait il
rien vu plus loin
oui je sais pas moi j'ai une petit à
petit j'ai d é tat évocation j'ai une
petite idée donc je dévoilerai pas tout
fait pas ce qu'il faut attendre le coup
de sirène alors voilà donc là on l'a on
et nicolas dans une variante on est dans
un foisonnement de tactique là c'est à
dire que là il faut vraiment avoir tout
calculé parce qu'il ya beaucoup des
changes
il faudra la faire avoir su jugé la
position finale pour savoir qui quel
avantage au final absolument alors les
pièces blanches sont plus d'action que
les pièces noires on voit que sont mieux
mobiliser donc les blancs dans cette
position complexe ont plus de
possibilités que les noirs pour faire
des menaces et je crois que le facteur
du roi blanc moins bien protégée
désormais par rapport au roa noir les
moins importants sans doute que
l'activité des pièces blanches la
colonne de la tour mahler plein
donc la promesse la colonne de la tour
sur le sur le roi adverse
le cavalier blanc peut sauter en plein
centre éventuellement pour soutenir le
pion avancé
voilà sur la case des cinq ce cavalier
pourrait contrôler des cases noires
proche du roi adverse
je crois que presque toutes les pièces
blanches hormis la tour à gauche à 1
sont en jeu alors que pour les noirs
c'est moins le cas parce que
je trouve que la dame noire est moins
bien placé que la dame blanche pour
faire des monnaies mais il ya encore
rien d'évident il faut que les lignes de
jeu forcé soit bonne pour un conte pour
l'autre pour se faire une opinion
exact alors voyons maintenant donc les
noirs choisissent d'abord avant de
reprendre ce fou de faire un échec
en reprenant en faisait un échange de
fou finalement non juste une précision
j'aime beaucoup aimé le commentaire de
nicolas parce que sa kippa de l'activié
les pièces et fou pranger de est un
mauvais coup parce que il élimine une
bonne monnaie d'échangé
et c'est là que moment critique donc à
monde donc j'espère que ça pourra
répondre finalement la prochaine fois
qu'il viendra parce que j'ai la question
d'interrogations que j'allais poser
oui je pense qu'il faut proches des deux
n'est pas un bon coup mais j'aimerais en
fait j'aimerais qu'on revienne un petit
peu la partie pour montrer pourquoi fou
projet donnait pas un bon coup on valoir
au revoir on va regarder le thème de la
partie mais on se remettra de se
rappeler que [ __ ] on chez d'autres
mauvais coup et on verra pourquoi donc
là si elle reprend du roi voilà
et maintenant bon il est noir évidemment
reprennent la pièce qui étaient prises
en schiste donc égalité matérielle pour
l'instant oui et la série noire
seulement 21e coujoux un coup a priori
un peu surprenant il prend finalement le
fou et 6 avec sa tour alors qu'on sait
que mon tour a priori les plus fortes
comme fou mais lens il donne du matériel
finalement c'est le bon coup mais le
seul coup aussi finalement parce que les
noirs commencé à voir des pièces bien
placé le fief 6 était bien placé la tour
en 1 8
comment savoir une action sur e4 donc
tout point f6 c'est un bon coup c'est le
sur le coup pour essayer de ce faux en
fait devenus
devenez une autre très gênant et aider
les noirs dans leur défense
donc il fallait emmener il faut dire que
ce coup fragilisé terriblement le roi
noir région et puis les blancs vont
jouer pour mettre en valeur leurs
monstres qui va apparaître sur la case
des 5 et le cavalier sa cavale et qu'il
est rétabli complètement dominateurs
il va y avoir la colonne h aussi mais
maintenant et donc je donne 35 tours h1
et il va y avoir donc mais quand on voit
la tour à 8 ans ou à gauche on peut se
dire que le cavalier est aussi fort
sinon plus fort entre cette tour parce
que quand c'est un sacrifice qui à court
terme mais pas risquer du tout si les
pièces venait trop passé changé
notamment les dames alors ça serait un
gros risque d'avoir sacrifié la qualité
mais les dames sont encore là pour
longtemps je pense alors on va voir
donc les noirs évidemment comprennent
qu'on utilisait nicolas laurent devoir
maintenant est très affaibli puisque il
a enlevé un grand pions qu'il défendrait
devant donc il susceptible de recevoir
des d échec justement et les blancs
maintenant pour en profiter tout
simplement d'abord ils prennent sur
fermeture h5 qui traînait depuis un
moment
alors c'est là qui est qui et que je
trouve en arrière si on remet finalement
virtuellement parce qu'ils ont revue
virtuellement le roi en h1 si on remet
leur là mais on achète tout à leur
argent mais change des fous le fou en h
3 wii et le fou en g2 et bien maintenant
les noirs ou le coup spectaculaire roi
g7
on comprend en jeu 7 qui fait venir tout
de suite la tour en 9 8 et posent des
problèmes aux blancs et peut-être que
les blancs sont perdus moi j'ai analysé
cette position quoi non c'est sont pas
perdues je pense qu'elle doit se jouer
on pourrait prendre le fou oui mais tour
à tour achevé à huy chrh madame oui non
entourage parce que la dame est quand
même ce serait très faible
très faible voilà donc voilà une
solution sur l'attaqué qui aurait été
possible pour les noix l'aca ne pas
échanger et justement
donc comme je redis j'aime beaucoup de
commentaires ni colère parce que les
pièces sont comme une valeur c'est le x
3 était beaucoup plus fort que le fou
j'ai deux c'était une pièce active
il ne fallait pas les changer en plus le
roi est en h1 et est fragilisée alors la
fois de champion du portugal pour
pouvoir ça parce que non mais je pense
que juste sur la valeur des pièces on se
rend compte que vous projetez de n'est
pas un bon coup dont on peu on peut vous
êtes donc au vu de cette variante où
maintenant les blancs ont des
possibilités d'attac avec la dame
collard leroy plus l'atout russie voilà
ce qui peut en un coup participé à
l'attaqué se mettant sur ces deux cas on
peut dire que vu de cette variante on
peut dire que donc les
les chansons on aurait dû garder une
pièce finalement défensive se fout ce
fourrage trois auraient été en fait une
pièce qui aurait gêné attaque
oui je pense que maintenant
effectivement la colonne h ouverte pour
la tour blanche la saison va avoir un
effet décisif mais bien sûr donc la
chance finalement un peu made in en
feuillets fischer disait que les
champions une seule des champions de la
chance alors on va voir on va voir les
talents les noirs donc essayé de se
défendre maintenant de défendre un peu
leurs droits en ramenant la tour ici ils
attaquent la dame blanche
beaucoup de défenses et ils peuvent
ramener éventuellement la tour sur une
case défensivement donc les blancs
choisissent de mettre la dame en h4
ils attaquent alors ils continuent de
menacer cette tour de niro machin vers
un échec mortels ici puisque ça serait
un math et aussi ils attaquent
géographie ce pourquoi est-ce qu'il n'a
pas mis salaire plutôt en h6 ça n'aurait
pu il aurait pu aussi c'est vrai qu'a
priori on allait jouer peut-être été
noir aurait pu mettre leur d'abord la
case et fuites et proposé un échange
alors que là la dame blanche et et se
soustrait ou échange possible c'est
comme s'il était bien nicolas - ya deux
pièces plus c'est facile pour la défense
en défense il faut noter aussi que le
coutour des noirs là il est destiné à
prendre le cavalier sans compter le
matériel lecavalier sera tellement fort
que immédiatement j'imagine la tour
noire ou s'ils se sacrifièrent est aussi
peut-être pour faire une contre attaque
sur le pont g3 masquer le prochain coup
je vois que ces tours j'ai cinq noms il
semblerait que alors on va voir quelle
est quelle est donc la suite avec donc
pour les noirs le coup tour je vais
manger sain qui protège un peu le renoir
qui essaie maintenant de mettre une
pièce devant son roi pour éviter des
échecs désagréable chimiques mais ce
peut être par exemple de jouer aux dames
g4 pour échanger les dames et de faire
un petit voile aller faire une petite
menace sur g31 un set d'avancé 8
pourrait effectivement venu sur la
musique a échangé contre jeu et à se
contredire la menace de match malgré ce
qui se passe
alors voyons voilà ce que sur la menace
de match voilà cyril choisi de mettre sa
tour sur la case h1 et menace tout
simplement maintenant dame à schwyz
échec et mat donc on l'a on voit la
batterie des pièces lourdes et qui n'a
pas pu être possible s'il n'est pas
échangé le fou si on n'avait pas échangé
une fois je croise aurait peut-être pas
été possible et on voit aussi pourquoi
ce fameux pions
qu'on me disait qu'il aurait été mieux h
tête au début de certaines taxes et que
maintenant il manque cruellement des
pions pour défendre le roi d'engager
d'exception avait été encore très bien
posté comment dit on va s'arrêter là si
ma grand-mère faisait du vélo
alors voyons donc maintenant les noirs
denses obligés de jouer un coup de fuite
finalement c'est un coup de fuite le
coup droit complètement force et il n'y
avait pas d'autre façon de pareilles
matt valable
quant à cyril a tout vu il fait un échec
sur lequel on adversaire saman répondu
en marge leers est donc là les noirs on
on croit qu'on possibilité soit de
mettre la cour c'est le meilleur coach
le plus le plus défensif
après une semaine à tours il est blanc
aurait pu prendre peut-être même si
saddam g4 et jeu contre attaque sur
plancher trois dames g4me la tour sont
venus faire un nom des échecs tour j'ai
vite c'est parfait sinon c'est pas
facile encore nantes où je sais tu étais
vraiment le meilleur coût parce que bon
ça part en même temps ça laisse un peu
de contre jeu pour les noirs mais le
qu'après le coup qui fait les c'est quoi
ton perdu que c'est donc à l'attaqué
très forte le roi noir doit de répondre
à des échecs alors que le droit de
l'homme on est pas encore on est très
sûr il est très sûr mais il est bien
protégé donc les noirs choisissent de
mettre leurs droits sur la case 1,8 et
savent à cazaux cette somme plus beaux
sinon il ya sur la liste seraient
tournoi ah oui mais ensuite mes moyens
je perds suit la position serait perdu
grâce aux pions c6 qui est très avancé
mais là il faut ajouter au g7 parce que
maintenant sur le coup suivant les
copies bardem leur fusion grand dam 36
attaques à tour j'ai cinq ans qu'on perd
un temps finalement plus voilà cette
tour est attaquée ce matin la deuxième
tour devenir un match ne faut absolument
clé noir par exemple être là tout ranger
vite exactement pour protéger le match
est requis il a un peu craqué sous les
pressions disons mais bon c'est un peu
logique puisque c'est c'est la pression
blanche est tellement forte
alors les noirs jouent le trou logique
szczesny et peut-être d'un et pouvait
jouer d'alger 4 quand même non vous
pouvez alors nicolas propose le ku'damm
ce pour les noirs sur la case g4
maintenant peut-être kibia tour a chuté
chèque
maintenant les blancs auraient fait
échec avec un taux de retour est
couverte chante l'amour cours protégé
par la dame g4 tout reproche évite tout
projet vite avec échecs dames projet 8
et 15,8 et finalement le cavalier à la
rescousse menaces mat sur la case
recettes et aussi une fourchette
sûrement pratiquement parra pierre dans
le dos mais chut si je voudrais mais
fuit pour paris m on essaie de canaliser
cette manne
on avait ces sept matches quand même
c'est le couple dames et cavaliers sont
très très forts sont supérieurs aux
couples dame est fou par exemple donc il
s'agit bien et contrôle des cases contre
toutes les cases ensemble et contre les
cases diverses que c'est vraiment très
fort le couple d'amis cavalli c'est donc
un match de quarts temps nicolas est
perdant
absolument oui alors les noirs
choisissent quand même de jouer le
coutour g8
hélas comme dit jean pierre mercier donc
ça en brique dans libération nicolas
mais blanc et blanc jouer son match et
jouer formate exactement inversées
l'avoir jamais traumat qui jouent tour à
suit exactement tout à fait cyril a vu
d'abord le coup enfin cesser la même
variante est en fait d'abord le coup car
il est des cinq effectivement cours
forcément eu des pièces qui force les
noirs de protéger vis surtout sa menace
maths et ça empêche le remords de sortir
sur le canot de 7 sa force de 270,8
issoudun donc sa forte pour les noirs le
ku'damm en des mythes et le joli coup
nicolas et toura suite comme un tour je
suis devant et maintenant effectivement
tourache 8
et si les noirs prennent la dame tout
simplement on prend d'abord la tour avec
échec et mat
le club ayant des cinq empêchant le roi
noir de sortir et le fameux pioncer 6
tout à l'heure qui protège la case 17
d'où l'intérêt d'avoir des pièces qui
comprend les cases proche du camp ennemi
mais je crois que c'est fini les
continuer un petit peu nombreux ces
crimes at il annoncé
il a joué pour le futur
les trois fuites qui auraient tarder le
mat deux coups weepu joue touré fuite
aussi de paris tourcoing le fuit 3 prend
la fuite des mois ils sont rois f8
effectivement qui provoque it qui et
protège la tour tout simplement damage
six échecs leroy revient est obligé de
revenir et tout reprendre pour matt donc
là ou alors tous réfutent les noirs à
vendre de tourcoing tours et fuite
tourcoing fuite et pour tous à 8 tours
points fis 3 prend la fuite
damages fuite maintenant c'est horrible
composite cédant qu'on peut résumer que
enfin de syrie vers sony a profité plus
des erreurs sur l'adversaire en fait sur
cette partie bah disons bon il a risqué
je pense qu'il aurait un moment du jeu
plus dynamique et prendre un bon
avantage et il a joué un petit peu
essayé de jeu prophylactique dame de
russian essayer de préparer mais bon les
noirs ont très bien répondu ont très
bien défendu et après ils ont ils
blanc était un petit peu chanceuse en
tout cas un joli tableau 2 bat final est
très bien c'est une torture position
alors d'ailleurs comme on peut en
trouver dans le brouillard
alors pourquoi j'en parle nicolas on
allait revenir mais pourquoi pourquoi je
vais en parler c'est parce que les
bonnes librairies notamment à paris
c'est
variante il ya aussi une dame inopérant
de haut niveau est spécialisé dans les
échecs mais voilà et notamment l'opéra
on a rencontré le directeur de l'opéra
au jardin du luxembourg donc encore une
fois la novation commune il y avait tout
le monde
senna nous retrouvons vraiment tout le
monde puisque à part les joueurs
d'échecs les personnalités ne retrouvons
les gens qui font le dessous de la scène
et chicken avec didier chevalier donc
qui est le chef et patron et
propriétaire du damier l'opéra bonjour
didier bons joueurs et loire est ce que
tu peux présenter rapidement ton
activité et le pourquoi es tu venu ici
en gros bas nous sommes venus ici en
tant qu'invité de l'opéra une
inauguration des jeux que vous avez vu
chaque jeu et fx et donc on a été invité
par le président du sénat lors d'un
déjeuner ensuite d'une inauguration à
laquelle tout le monde participe
maintenant c'est très convivial et ça et
j'espère que ça participera au
développement du jeu d'échecs d'accord
et donc ta spécialité c'est le d'avis de
l'opéra comme tout le monde le sait
c'est un magasin spécialisé dans le jeu
d'échec on existe maintenant depuis 25
ans et on a tout ce qu'il faut pour le
joueur d'échecs échiquier livres et ses
logiciels et tu n'es pas sans savoir que
ça peut être utile tout à fait donc
complet technologique le 2 mai l'auteur
merci merci dans les jardins du sénat
avec le diu organisateurs de cette
manifestation
bertrand guyard bonjour bonjour donc toi
c'est plutôt le côté passion c'est la
passion ça fait des années que je joue
ici dans les jardins du luxembourg dans
le jardin du sénat aux échecs et ça fait
des années que j'attrape des scolioses
ça fait des années que je me disais ça
serait bien qu'on est très beau jeu
l'échec est jeune on en parlait on en
parlais avec mon ami yves marek et un
jour il a été nommé conseiller du
président du sénat il se rêve est devenu
réalité et grâce à lui mais je crois que
c'est la meilleure chose à faire c'est
peut-être lui demandait de savoir
comment il a réussi à convaincre
monsieur consuel président du sénat de
mettre des échiquiers ici donc monsieur
yves marek vous êtes voilà donc
donc on a vu
cheval donné donc je chausse les
chevaliers pardon sur la donne et c'est
là notre joueur d'échecs
ce chevalier directeur de des dames et
l'opéra et donc date rendue hier qui
organise et qui a organisé avec yves
marek du sénat donc 7,7
cet événement une gestation cette
manifestation voilà on va retrouver
maintenant donc le vis donc le
vice-champion de france david martial
encore une fois on l'a vu est moins
jamais vraiment nicolas beaucoup de
monde cela redonne secoué il manquait
seulement ce parce qu'ils auraient aimé
revoir ça fait longtemps que j'avais pas
vu il était invité il n'est pas venu
il manquait aussi fabrice luchini
l'acteur oui qu'est si volubile wii qui
donnait venir aussi qui aurait très bien
parlé sans doute du jeu d'échecs s'il
est des bijoux comme on l'a vite et je
pense qu'il doit y jouer mais il y avait
des personnalités intéressantes
notamment le metteur en scène jean
becker qui a l'air d'être un bon joueur
d'échecs mois qu'on en entend amener une
tare guen dernière d'ailleurs comment
s'appelle-t-il bertrand guyard mais dit
qu'il valait à peu près mille huit cents
lots et avec josé giovanni tv josé
giovanni keller le catégorie en dessous
il y avait chez vainement à qui et on
voit que il joue pas souvent ils adorent
ils étaient contents mais même si on
regarde les coups qu'il a effectuée
c'est un peu ridicule mais il était plus
fort que ça jean becker parce qu'avant
avant cette manifestation avait fait
deux parties me contre etienne bacrot en
simultané au etienne avait ni gd pas
encore positif compris jean becker bon
c'est fait aujourd'hui les heureux et
d'autres s'ils ne risquent pas de passer
des réalisateurs qui sont bons en
déchets qui est à chaussy away ce stage
qui qui à 2006 qui est donc les gens du
cinéma une les échecs ou des voiliers et
oui vous allez là aussi des sciences en
calmant un peu tout le monde c'est vrai
on va retrouver les terrains
david marciano pour une interview non
non la part donc donc on le verra pas le
passé on a passera donc une autre fois
donc le championnat du monde des juniors
donc s'est terminée sur la victoire du
russe au gars qui donc en pour souligner
ont tous signalé moi ce que je voulais
dire jamais parlé au début c'est que ces
championnats du monde juniors c'est très
important
voilà parce que tous les champions du
monde toutes catégories ont été arrondis
commencer le vivier c'est le vigile les
futurs champions c'est là qu'on trouve
effectivement les futurs champions du
mans mais comme actuellement les
championnats du monde sait pas trop ce
que ça va se finir les pauvres j'ai peur
qu'ils qui puisse pas continuer
brillamment leur carrière à ce propos on
a vu la réapparition de qualif man à
noter aussi dans l'actualité qui a joué
pour son équipe de saint pétersbourg et
qui a permis pour le curé pétersbourg
oui la coupe d'europe de se qualifier
pour la phase finale
les qualifs man a fait deux parties nul
contre des joueurs une moyenne de 2550
pour un champion du monde on attend
mieux mais on a pu quand même mesuré le
la qualité de cali fans et à doter dans
l'actualité aussi stéphane qui va y
avoir bientôt les transferts de joueurs
en nationale 1 qui vont être connus
empreintes du magic va avoir un
bouleversement parce qu'il ya une
nouvelle loi sur le nombre de joueurs
étrangers par équipe qui a été modifié
et ça ça fait grincer quelques dents il
ya eu plusieurs présidents de clubs qui
n'étaient pas d'accord avec cette mesure
disant que c'était du protectionnisme
avec l'arrêt bosman on n'avait pas
vraiment légal c'est une région dans le
poser parce que mais il se trouve qu'en
fait il ya beaucoup de fédérations qui
reviennent sur cet arrêt bosman
il ya au football notamment l'espagne
l'italie qui se demandent s'il faut
parvenir un système de limitation pour
favoriser les jeunes du cru
on verra en tout cas quand on aura
l'information finale ce qu'on peut dire
encore une fois c'est que donc
championne jeune henri fermin et je
crois que les championnats du monde d
autres catégories donc moins de 16 ans -
de 14 à 18 ans ont démarré où ont
démarré en espagne je sais que tu sais
plus exactement et je sais qu'il ya
laurent frayssinet très grand espoir
également voilà qu'on a vue à besançon
éliminer presque bacrot oui en match de
barrage avant les demi-finales gp et là
ça s'est terminé à la sixième partie de
départage qui fait beaucoup de progrès
et cette fois ci les redoutables bon
donc voilà donc
je vous donne rendez-vous à une
prochaine fois nicolas giffard donc
c'est du banc je suis ravi de venir à
chaque fois et nous on est ravis de
t'accueillir la semaine prochaine josé
peut-être sera présente son projet
d'ailleurs aux échos la semaine
prochaine donc sur des gonades
l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs merci
on